all that's left is your signature and
we're good to go
[Music]
now you're officially a disciple of
God's promise welcome welcome to God's
promise you are at an age where you are
especially vulnerable to evil
we're gonna spend our time together
investigating what led you here in the
past I would resort to self pleasure but
then when I learned that that was a sin
also I stopped
Kameron your struggle is with the sin of
same-sex attraction you're facing the
consequences of your actions and it's
ugly why she gets such a [ __ ] I guess
it's like having your own busy villain
only this one won't let you jerk off you
don't really seem like a counter person
that be here we didn't have a choice did
you
[Music]
I mean couldn't we just walk off and go
where what's worse karaoke night or
living on the streets tough call you'd
rather hang back are you I bet
tell us about that girl you knew from
home
the first step is for you to stop
thinking of yourself as a homosexual
I don't think of myself as I'm a sexual
I don't really think of myself as
anything [ __ ] this place I'm tired of
feeling disgusted with myself
you have no idea what you're doing
[Music]
you
[Music]
you